this show really loves being in France
because the general concupisent
surrounding Archer I have to specify
that I'm talking about the country and
not a person we have a butcher a baker
and a latte maker and that's just not
how you rub a dub dub this is also not
sexual because this is what was there
Lana managing to bury two Salient
pronouns in your Snappy 7 word m
conversation cold
[Music]
open Archer murders two police officers
in Cold Blood and laughs at off I
continue to get the impression that this
series isn't entirely embedded in
reality morality or another ality that
finishes that thought nicely did you
want to finish shutting your big fat
negative wordsy mouth oh Archer my
friend I have barely begun which cannot
be taught by the way like a poet Archer
mind for Archer Lana sees this truck
coming for quite some time but thinks
that calmly repeating Archer will work
just as well as saying hey there's a
speeding truck coming right at us this
drawing of a flaccid is he trying to
turn that thing on look at this o n
nothing Cheryl's really this stupid I'd
love to know how she manages to put
these earrings in every day without
setting fire to well everything har we
have this whole huge history together
Dylan we don't have this whole huge
history thinking it's the size of your
history that counts using a mirror to
reflect the laser beam back into the
laser this scene suggests that the
villain stripped Barry and Lana but
decided to leave them with a mirror or
Barry or Lana somehow knew they'd need a
mirror and hid one in their person sorry
I took so long and then I'm accidentally
inside you not a problem burying your
lead I wonder who packed his stuff
because we all know archers never put a
condom in a box key card oh de God
either Archer has a very dextrous or the
animators weren't interested in
animating the departure of this card
from his person in any way that makes
any kind of sense it's probably the
dextrous thing
God damn it when do we get a bulletproof
door Archer will walk off this shattered
kneecap as if his gun was loaded with
Pixie kisses and warm hugs I'm going to
pain you dearly Woodhouse when I peel
all your skin off with a fencing knife
how does Archer expect to get hold of a
flensing knife on such short notice a
butter knife would be much easier to
find it trust me it'd be much more
satisfying why well because this dull
you twit it'll hurt more I wonder if any
of the characters in the show think it's
weird that their portraits look more
realistic than they do Odin won't hire
him after the stunt he pulled in Berlin
teasing us with a flashback to a mission
that looks like it would have made a
better episode than the one we're
watching these poorly drawn breasts I
just don't see why you need this not
seeing why we need this you're a natural
bet it's all that lacrosse at boarding
school huh interesting considering he's
swinging a polo Mallet which has about
as much in common with lacrosse as
hockey and to be clear I'm not
acknowledging either of them is a real
sport that actually exists because no
concrete evidence can be found the
Internet is just is littered with fake
Wikipedia Pages it's clearly a
conspiracy this poor woman who's been
waiting on standby since halfway through
episode 3 and how dare you steal my son
away from me if only you had something
to hold things in place so they couldn't
get away from you like the tape on your
desk why is it there if you're never
going to use it why I said don't come in
here Grand what did I say he said do not
come in someone here should be saying do
not come in but it is an Archer
considering the previous atrocities the
show has happily shown us I have to know
what finally crossed the line and
required blurring do you know howed up
something must be for Archer to blur it
then go check your Telex I don't know
what's weirder that there are only 32
intelligence agencies in the world that
most of these acronyms are actually real
or that this fax machine has a sent to
All intelligence agencies in the world
button if you love it put a ring on it
if you love it enough to put a ring on
it you should probably stop calling it
it so you take him to the basement you
put one in his ear this kind of vague
instruction is how you end up with a
piercing you don't want to this day I'll
never understand why that guy was
instructed to put one in my love sausage
ruined a package of perfectly good
brought worst this insanely huge lobby
with approximately 177,000 ft of wasted
space this building clearly has more
than 13 floors but the indicators on the
ground floor apparently don't give a sh
no baby I am putting you in the corner
making me realize that even with all the
horizontal Mambo that goes on in this
show there's actually little to know
Dirty Dancing All right you yellow sons
of [__] mallerie says offensive
because she's blackout drunk has no
filter and no real understanding of
right or wrong and the audience is
supposed to find it funny just because
it's a terrible thing to say cliche so
just sit there undo this ooh ooh what we
can't miss Archer it's too late except
it isn't because in about 4 minutes Lana
will save the day and it will take her
all 3 and a half seconds to work out how
to undo this making us have to guess
whether or not this yo-yo and this
wiring diagram are part of some very
specific fetish Archer oh come on Lana
why the hell are whoa whoa whoa la lana
no this execution happens off screen to
confirm that it is not real also how did
Archer know to play along Lana manages
to perfectly communicate and execute
this ruse in seconds and somehow Archer
doesn't fck it up by having sex with
something Barry does this make up for
franois it does other Berry it sure does
the on line pitch for my Off Broadway
adaptation of flasho somehow makes its
way into the episode so I can send a
Telex from Odin to make the burn notice
from your mother look like an Odin black
flag wait how is that going to solve
anything why would Odin send a Burn
Notice out for an opposing agent and
then immediately admit to it why
wouldn't the world just believe that
Isis had set this whole thing up to make
Odin look bad also isn't Archer screwed
regardless hasn't his code name real
name and picture been distributed to the
world's agencies also also the also that
loved me what's stopping Odin from
sending another Telex saying that the
original Burn Notice was legit and an
Isis agent snuck into their Building
attacked Barry D the head of HR and then
sent the Telex to make them look bad I
think the moral here is fax machine Mach
were never a good idea these poorly
drawn people fornicating in a public
library while the cast of Hamilton
watches on and sings encouraging
affirmations to them wait you don't see
that well I have to get cill who's on FR
Bois fun moment of catching cill with
his pants down but you thought he was in
the lobby so there's no reason for the
elevator to even stop on the grenade
storage floor that chick was like the P
of anal saying this without knowing for
a fact that P wasn't the P of anal if I
had shot you in the face I'd be living
here getting curtsied at by servants
trust us Lana we're equally confused as
to why you didn't do it two roads
diverged in a wood and you chose Archer
and that has made all the inference I
don't recall ever seeing a welcome mat
at your back door if you're showing up
at someone's back door then you've
reached a level of casual familiarity
that would not necessitate such a formal
greeting come on in grab a beverage make
yourself at home wait but wait would
that chew you up me and you a little
Revenge an H seems unimpressed by this
suggestion but to be fair to Archer he
didn't specify who would be on the
receiving end of this alternate ending
you wearing a seat belt uh no I
good Archer survives this but please
don't let our sitting the outcome
discourage the
attempt read my please no I cannot be
fired I'm fired
a oh my are you aiming for these people
no maybe that's mine and if you ever get
tired of playing JV ball you know where
to find us yeah yeah business card cocky
so I don't play by the rules mother I'm
a pretty damn good web designer time to
face Destiny time to face gravity so
will you please just help me up I'm
going to enjoy watching you fall good
cuz I like I said I bet I just reek reek
that's a good name for you because there
is lamp everywhere I Love Lamp